We have 2 ways of finding this out.
We can either run the whole thing with this input
or we can also go through it and figure out what's going on.
The interesting thing about this input
is that it mixes double quotes and single quotes.
I am going to use the green color
for section where tag mode on,
and I'm going to use the pink color
for sections where quote is on.
So initially, we are in tag mode.
It starts precisely here, and it goes up to the place where we find the quote.
While we are processing the quote, quote mode is also turned on.
But now we see the second quote in here, and quote mode ends.
We are still in tag mode.
Now we see another quote, you see where the problem is.
We don't discriminate between double and single quotes,
and therefore, a string that starts with a
double quote can also end in a single quote.
See, here again we are in tag mode,
but now we also start quote mode.
And now as we are at the greater than sign that is the end of the tag,
we are still in quote mode,
and therefore, tag mode does not end.
And sense we stay in quote mode until the very end,
all of this is considered to be part of the tag,
and therefore, the answer is the result is the empty string.
This is the correct result.